what's the basic concept or maybe i
should say what's the basic building
block
that makes up an artificial neural
network
and yeah that's right so um you can
think about this you can actually use
two different words
um where neural comes from is neurons
right namely the basic building block of
the brain
but in computer terms right and in
networking terms actually we've done
communication systems so
we get this right we call those neurons
nodes
all that means is there these individual
units which connect to other units
okay now just before we go any further
this is a really fascinating idea okay
because i know you guys could go and do
the research later on
to find out when exactly we discovered
that neurons existed right and that the
brain wasn't just
like a squishy thing that was made up of
random tissues but there are these
things and they talk to each other
with electrical signals that's really
profound right
i remember i was talking to a friend at
uni this was years ago when i was at uni
and uh she's a med student and she's
talking about the fact that in
anatomy and physiology okay the entire
human body
basically is comprehensively understood
like the liver
we know everything there is to know
about the liver and its function and its
structure
okay the only part of the human body
where anatomy and physiology are still
kind of like
we're still trying to work it out is the
human brain
which is very interesting because the
human brain is like the one thing that
in terms of science
we have inside knowledge of right inside
knowledge like we actually we're in
our brain all the time so we kind of
know how it works and yet it's the most
mysterious part
of who we are so i see that's a little
interesting
now neurons nodes what's the key idea
right that these are all connected to
each other
in a partial mesh now when i say partial
mesh
that's kind of a bit of a misnomer
because you get the idea that oh they're
connect they're interconnected but
they're not that interconnected
but the fact is right every neuron has
so many connections with all the other
neurons it's just it's impossible to
illustrate okay and actually one of the
things they're trying to do right now
um not the human genome project which is
about mapping human dna
but the human connectome project which
is about mapping the connections of the
human brain
um it's nuts like to try and visualize
it is crazy so
this is the basic idea right now coming
back to the question
if that's the basic concept right why is
it important
why is it sort of better in some ways
then all of these guys okay what do you
think what did you get out of the video
what makes this approach better yeah
okay thank you
now we sent this right this is the
limitation here that
these pieces to make a decision maybe
they can make it faster like you don't
need to go through millions of versions
of the spreadsheet
to get one that works and tells you your
bmi and then gives you a recommendation
you maybe
go through like nine or ten versions
okay so a disadvantage
is that it takes a long time to get a
workable system
but time of course to a computer is
relative
right so you know when the presenter was
talking about the millions of times it
has to go through
a situation well our computers they do
exactly that every second
right millions and millions of
operations so
even though there's a long time involved
and that's a disadvantage okay
um because we've got the raw computing
power
of of these microprocessors and
electronic systems that's why
the disadvantage turns out to be not so
much of a disadvantage
and the advantage of course is it can
learn
now this is tricky right
can the neural network learn on its own
by itself and the answer is
ah right so the answer is kind of right
um here's what it mean here's what we
mean uh and here's the question i'm
trying to pose right
can um and this is actually i mean i
don't mean it but this is the acronym
that's used for
in artificial your networks can they
learn and the word i'm going to use is
autonomously okay
question okay can they learn
autonomously
the first answer yes right
is that given this set of inputs
and a set of expected outputs right like
for instance if you um
if we were a mortgage broker or
something like that right we're trying
to work out okay how much were we
willing to lend someone
what you do is you take your history of
data and all the people and the inputs
about them that you know
like their current income where they
live their age and so on and so forth
right
and then you would take your historical
decisions right this is how much i let
this person
and this is how much i didn't lend this
person right you take all of that
together and say okay did it go well did
it go badly whatever
you feed that to your artificial neural
water network and it will work out
the transfer functions of the weights
and all that kind of thing right so
yes given
appropriate data
okay given that set of inputs and the
set of expected
outputs okay now that part is crucial
right so it's a little bit like
you guys doing an exercise uh in maths
in a textbook right
and you've got the inputs they leave the
question but in order to actually learn
whether you're doing it right you need
the set of expected outputs you need the
answers at the back
otherwise you're like i'm doing these
questions i don't know if i'm doing it
right or not you've got no idea whether
you're actually making any progress
in improving okay so you need the
expected outputs that's crucial to the
whole learning
process therefore um
can it learn autonomously well no
because where is it going to get those
expected apples from right and it
doesn't just make them up i mean the
point is you can't make them up they
have to be known beforehand
right so no because that data
still needs to be provided
still must be provided
now the important thing is the reason
why we still say
the artificial new network it really can
learn in a genuine way
is that this data you must provide about
inputs and expected outputs
you can provide as much as that as you
like to all of these and they won't
learn anything
right they will not change or adapt okay
that's not the nature of the system
whereas the structure of an artificial
new nerve is to take that expected data
that's set and then to adjust itself in
response to that
so it really is yes it really is yes